oh maybe there was a key over by him the
lantern I didn't see probably behind a
boy or something well was that oh oh
look at this mini Bab oh it's so Mandy
Oh gonna call you MIDI void mark you're
gonna come in on adventure mini bleh
mark maybe I gotta smash to open in the
keys inside you know I never hurt you I
would never hurt you my little biscuit
okay still found the key jus smell the
key around here do you smell the key
behind those let's players
let's Clarence a bully jus cuz you were
smaller kill him Oh maybe there's a
spare key or a crowbar in the storage
area is it dangerous
yeah it's okay Thank You mini boy mark
mark I Adam I had in my arms Oh gimme
gimme gimme
I can't think about I can't pick up MIDI
boy bark any blame or get out I don't
even have that I have no hands anymore
then just stick okay mark I have to
finish this you guard the demons from
coming back for me thank you baby boy
bark I was always thinking of you even
in the darkest of pipes
oh oh look at this tiny box oh it's so
tiny
I'm gonna call you tiny box Tim you're
gonna come with me on an adventure tiny
box Tim if I gotta smash you open to the
keys inside you know I would know you
might little biscuit okay still haven't
found the key
you smell a key around here MIDI boy
bark you will always be my bestest of
friends